[Musique]
parent
[Applaudissements]
alors tous les matins j'arrive là
j'arrive au muséum d'histoire naturelle
dans le jardin des plantes
mon bureau il est quelque part un peu
plus loin sur sur la droite et je passe
devant la statue de la marque la marque
comme le pis les salles le dit qu'il
invente heures de la théorie de
l'évolution et chaque matin je le plains
un peu parce qu'il n'aura pas été
prophète ni en son pays ni en ce bas
monde
oui car l'évolution tout le monde y
croit
surtout en france c'est un produit des
lumières on est loin on est loin encore
d'agir avec alors l'évolution bien sûr
c'est d'abord la marque qui a repéré que
les espèces changé au cours du temps et
qui finalement avec le transformiste le
transformiste va créer la première
brique de la théorie de l'évolution
et puis bien sûr il ya darwin qui va lui
trouver un mécanisme pour quoi les
espèces change eh bien c'est simplement
parce que les plus adaptés font plus de
descendants les moins adaptés font moins
de descendants et au total le lendemain
la biosphère a changé en fait ce que
darwin nous explique c'est qu'il y à un
tri c'est la sélection la sélection
naturelle et que ce tri trident une
variation des organismes mais il va
donner plus de descendants à ceux qui
sont adaptés etc des andes ressembleront
à leurs parents donc ni un changement il
ya un bug c'est que pour le coup à force
de trier de trier de trier de trier bas
la fin il ya plus de diversité or c'est
tout le contraire que nous apprend
l'histoire de la biosphère c'est que la
diversité l'augmentent donc il manque
quelque chose
ce qui fait que ni darwin ni la marque
n'avait encore toute l'histoire ne s'est
pas sien à toute l'histoire mais depuis
on a quand même trouvé un générateur de
diversité je voudrais vous parler de
quelqu'un qui est peu connue qui
s'appelle hugo de vries et hugo de vries
il ay travailler sur des fleurs les aux
notaires et hugo de vries a trouvé le
concept de mutation il a remarqué que
certains individus avaient des
variations qui apparaissait brutalement
et qu'ils transmettaient leur
descendance ce qui fait qu'à tout moment
apparaissait de la diversité de la
nouveauté adapté ou pas d'ailleurs
et donc aujourd'hui nous voyons le
darwinisme d'une autre façon
l'évolution telle qu'on la voit
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une
biodiversité dans laquelle se produisent
des mutations ces mutations entraîne une
grande variété de choses adapté ou non
et la sélection naturelle tri là dedans
et donne la biodiversité du lendemain et
ce cycle tourner perpétuellement voilà
je vous ai raconté la façon dont on voit
aujourd'hui l'évolution est d'ailleurs
tout le monde est d'accord avec ça sauf
que en fait personne sincère et j'ai
essayé de vous montrer à quel point
sincères pas on s'en sert pas même si
c'est une toile de fond et ça ça ça
abîme
ça pourrit un certain nombre de
discussions qu'on peut avoir est aussi
un certain nombre d'actes ou d'actions
que nous menons dans les discussions
qu'on peut avoir c'est pas d'une grande
importance mais ça révèle
l'incompréhension il ya cette discussion
autour des bernard l'hermite vous savez
ces crustacés car le corps mou alors
comme ils ont le corps mou il s'abrite
dans des coquilles de gastéropodes qui
sont morts et qui ont laissé leur
coquille
on dit souvent oui ben voilà l'ancêtre
des bains dans les remises il avait le
corps mou alors pour se protéger l'a mis
dans une coquille c'est aberrant
si cet ancêtre la a vu corps mou qui
n'était pas une coquille serait fait
bouffer depuis longtemps en réalité ce
qui s'est passé c'est que l'ancêtre du
vin noir et invite ses protégés en plus
de la carapace de son abdomen y ses
protégés dans une coquille et puis
finalement la protection de cette
coquille aidants et bien la fin ils
n'avaient plus besoin du tout d'avoir
propre sa propre peau qui soit rigide et
le corps est devenu mou on inverse en
fait
l'ordre des événements parce qu'on
réfléchisse pas en mécanisme alors là
c'est juste une idée reçue qui est un
qui peut fausse mais ça peut être plus
grave
ça peut être plus grave parce que
finalement comme on ne prend pas
vraiment en cause le mécanisme en compte
le mécanisme de l'évolution on va finir
par faire des erreurs des erreurs par
exemple on agriculture quand on a une
méthode de lutter conte l'appliquent
trop fort on va juste sélectionné ceux
qui la contournent je vais prendre
l'exemple de la résistance au btc une
toxine qui tue les insectes en amérique
du sud en afrique du sud par dont la
plante est d'aider maïs qui transgénique
produisait du bt donc 80% à une époque
des semences de maïs semés produisait
cette molécule est qu'est-ce que ça fait
bien en quelques années on a sélectionné
des insectes qui n'était plus tuer par
le bt le glyphosate aux états unis a été
appliquée en grande quantité le bilan
c'est qu'entre 95 et 2015 on a
sélectionné une trentaine d'espèces de
plantes résistantes au glyphosate qui
maintenant pousse très bien dans ses
champs là où en plus elles sont pas
ennuyés par les autres mauvaises herbes
pays qu'on a des victoires à la pyrrhus
on gagne le jour j mais le jour j + 1 on
a perdu nous ou nous outils et ça eh
bien ça joue jusque dans le domaine de
la santé
à force d'utiliser les antibiotiques de
façon non calculée par rapport à
l'évolution on voit une augmentation des
résistances aux antibiotiques et cette
augmentation progressive elle fait
qu'aujourd'hui dans un pays comme la
france on a 150 mille personnes par an
qui sont atteints par des bactéries
résistantes aux antibiotiques et 12000
parents qui en meurent dans le monde
on arrive à un total de sept cent mille
morts chaque année à cause des bactéries
résistantes aux antibiotiques et on
pense que d'ici 2050 on sera plutôt aux
alentours 60 millions c'est un vrai
drame qui se prépare et notre victoire
le jour j sur les bactéries
c'est notre défaite du jour j + 1
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas que les bactéries
qui pose problème
le vrai problème c'est surtout les
champignons et d'ailleurs c'est une
histoire d'évolution qui se cache
derrière
suivez-moi les champignons sont le plus
proches parents dans l'évolution les
plus proches parents des animaux et donc
ce qui est toxique pour un champignon
est souvent toxiques pour un animal
parce que c'était toxique sans doute
déjà pour l'ancêtre commun et donc on a
peu de fongicides qu'on puisse vraiment
utilisé sans que ce soit dangereux pour
l'homme je vous emmène au pays bas en
fait aux pays bas on a des cultures
florales qui sont très sensibles à un
champignon l'aspergillus fumigatus et
pour ça on traite beaucoup autre idole
mail aspergillus fumigatus c'est un
champignon qui peut affecter les poumons
de l'homme en une asperge il ose comme
on dit qui est invasive souvent et qui
touche 150 mille à cinq cent mille
personnes par an et surtout surtout 10%
des immunodéprimés
il ya que des triazoles pour souligner
sa et aux pays-bas dans certaines
régions autrefois
60% des infections pouvait être guéri
par l'application de triazole
aujourd'hui ce chiffre parce que
justement on a sélectionné des
résistances aux triazole il est tombé à
10%
90% des asperges il ose invasive ne
peuvent plus de soigner par les triazole
voyez c'est des histoires où finalement
le mécanisme de la sélection de façon
très très prédictible donne un résultat
qui est désastreux le jour suivant est
il sage ou dans des tas de choses je
suis sûr que la pêche à pied vous avez
déjà rejeté les petites crevettes ou les
petites palourdes en visant non à les
laisser grandir on reviendra plus tard
il ya même des réglementations pour ça
je vous parlais de servir les sardines
ya une taille minimale pour les péchés
sa part est de laisser grandir oui mais
en fait en rejetant les petits si jamais
vous avez les adultes 1 ils vont se
reproduire beaucoup plus que ceux qui
ont une grande taille à l'âge adulte qui
ont une bonne chance de se faire
repêcher et donc vous allez sélectionner
le nanisme
ça n'a pas loupé ces dix dernières
années les sardines de 1 an ont diminué
de 3 cm dans le golfe du lion et de 4 cm
dans le golfe de gascogne et elle pèse
beaucoup moins lourd c'est un vrai
désastre
rouler juste en train de sélectionner
des sardines de petite taille
voilà vous voyez que finalement c'est
les conduites complètement aberrante qui
montre que bien sûr on croit tous la
théorie de l'évolution mais en fait on
la prend pas en compte et nous victoire
et nos réussites du jour j sont nos
échecs du lendemain sont des victoires
que j'appellerai à la pyrrhus
alors vous allez me dire c'est
désespérant cette histoire parce que
films on peut rien faire sans faire de
bêtises non non j'ai maintenant vous
montrer quelques cas où justement on a
réussi à faire bien en termes évolutif
oui d exemple la trithérapie
vous savez cet ensemble de trois drops
qu'on donne aux gens qui sont malades du
sida
quels principes de la trithérapie est
très simple très simple vous avez trois
drogue qui ont trois sites d'action
différent et pour qu'un virus résiste à
la trithérapie il faut qu'il ait les
trois résistance ça veut dire trois
mutations
la probabilité d'une de ces mutations
c'est allez on va dire une chance sur un
million
et bien en statistiques c'est clair pour
avoir les trois mutations même temps
c'est une chance sur un million deux
millions deux millions
en d'autres termes mais c'est une chance
sur une quantité telle que dans une
population de virus dans un malade il
n'ya jamais assez de virus pour qui en
est un qui porte les trois mutations
donc on a dressé ici ce que j'appelle un
mur évolutif c'est à dire que c'est on
applique quelque chose qui bat on peut
pas évoluer pour le contourner et ça
c'est une vraie réussite et une réussite
empirique
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui a
été prédit par l'évolution une pensée
théorique non c'est un truc de médecins
astucieux empirique qui a marché et je
vais prendre un autre exemple agricole
vous allez voir savait qu'il avait une
histoire ça marche ça marche par hasard
et pas par théorie là c'est sûr qui a
pas de théorie derrière parce que je
vous emmène dans le sud de la chine dans
des milieux ruraux où on n'étudie pas
l'évolution mais où on cultive du riz le
riz c'est une de ces céréales qui est
sujette à des maladies et en particulier
la syrie qu la rieuse du riz qui tous
les ans détruits dans le monde
l'équivalent de l'alimentation de kiel
60 millions de personnes donc c'est
quand même pas une mais banal nous
sommes dans le sud de la chine dans la
zone d'origine du riz où il ya
énormément de parasites bien sûr puisque
y aussi les populations sauvages et nous
nous rendons dans le lieu à niang une
région où depuis plusieurs centaines
d'années il ya des méthodes de cultures
qui font qu' il n'y a pas de pierrick
hulard yaws alors même qu'on n'utilise
pas de fongicides et pourtant les
rendements ne sont pas font pas sourire
on est à 5 à 7 tonnes à l'hectare donc
c'est du très très bon rendement dans
une pratique traditionnelle
qu'est-ce qui se passe les collègues de
l'île d'er mixte de recherche bgp
l'équipe de jean benoît morel qui
travaille là dessus
ouias bonne idée d'aller là bas avec des
sociologues des anthropologues qui ont
un petit peu regardez qu'est ce qui se
passait en termes humains et ce qu'ils
ont découvert c'est que il est de règle
dans les interactions autour de
l'agriculture 1 quand vous allez chez
quelqu'un ils vous donnent des semences
donc chaque fois on peut avoir des
semences plus diversifiée et surtout de
il vous donne pas de conseils ne donne
pas de conseils du coup on sait pas trop
quoi semer en cerne tout ce qu'on a à la
maison y compris ce qu'on vient dans le
dans l'année d'avoir chez les voisins et
ça c'est vraiment important ce qui se
cache derrière c'est qu'on fait des
champs hyper divers tient là vous allez
voir la biodiversité qui devient un
outil il ya une telle diversité
génétique que
quand la maladie réussi sur un pied le
pied voisin est différent et la maladie
ne peut pas réussir sur le pied voisins
on a créé un paysage où les maladies et
d'ailleurs pas simplement là pierrick eu
la rieuse du riz ne se propage pas juste
à cause du paysage sans pesticides alors
oui vous voyez il ya vraiment des
méthodes mais là pour le coup c'est
vraiment de l'empirisme qui montre que
des fois on crée un paysage des
circonstances dans lesquelles il n'y a
pas moyen pour notre adversaire
d'évoluer vers une solution et ça ça se
décline d'ailleurs en agriculture chez
nous en introduisant de la diversité
dans les champs avec des cultures mixte
des cultures mélangeant différentes
variétés d'iai de l'agroforesterie
tout ça demande d'une certaine façon une
organisation qui n'existe bien sûr pas
de qu'est ce qu'on cultive dans deux
champs continue qu'est ce qu'on cultive
d'une année sur l'autre
m'enfin ce que ça montre c'est qu'il
existe bel et bien des scénarios dans le
temps des scénarios dans l'espace ou un
organisme dont on ne veut pas ne peut
pas évoluer ni trouvé la solution
ça s'appelle un mur sélectif ma fille au
gamer sélectif on sait pas forcément les
appliquer aux autres espèces les coûts
il se trouve que malheureusement on est
en train de s'appliquer
suivez-moi plus tôt il ya quelque chose
qui vous a peut-être frappé c'est que
dans les sociétés occidentales nos
compagnons beaucoup de mal à procréer il
ya beaucoup de couples qui n'arrive pas
à avoir d'enfant alors on peut se dire
que c'est l'actualité de nos compagnes
qui explique ça c'est en partie vrai il
ya un problème de fertilité féminine
mais il n'ya pas que ça quand on regarde
la production de spermatozoïdes chez les
hommes on s'aperçoit que depuis 73
nous avons perdu la moitié de la
quantité de pain est évident qu'on
produisait à cette époque là et dans les
spermatozoïdes qui restent ils sont 60%
moins fonctionnel d'une débâcle
alors il reste quelques uns pour faire
le travail mais le bihan c'est que nous
avons perdu deux là nous avons perdu de
la fertilité
pourquoi nous sommes exposés dans le
monde moderne à des kyrielles de
molécules nouvelles des kyrielles de
molécules nouvelles des parfums des
colorants
des produits stabilisant conservateur
des émulsifiants des pesticides et en
fait on voit très bien que plus on est
exposé à ces molécules comme par exemple
on est exposés à des pesticides
- effectivement on produit de sperme
quand on est un homme
en fait nous avons dressé un paysage
chimiques autour de nous auquel aucun
d'entre nous n'est adapté chacun d'entre
nous rencontrent une molécule qui le
fait sous performé alors bien sûr on ne
parle pas d'extinction ici on ne parle
que de réduction de son activité mais ça
c'est un mur sélectif
parce que personne finalement le passe
entre les gouttes ce mieux nous l'avons
nous même dressé devant nous car nous en
connaissons la théorie du mur mais ne
voyons pas la pertinence pratique même
les risques qu'il nous fait courir à
nous donc l'évolution c'est simple à
comprendre
tout le monde y croit on fait juste le
contraire de ce que l'évolution nous
dicte et pourtant on voit très bien que
des fois on est capable de faire des
choses très évolutif il brise très
évolutive mans pertinente y compris
contre nous mêmes la rupture c'est là où
on doit appeler la rupture la rupture
c'est le moment on va enfin faire de
l'évolution autre chose qu'un décor mais
réellement l'aune de notre action la
rupture c'est que l'évolution est une
belle au bois dormant et qui a peur que
quelqu'un aille réveiller élite
comment la réveiller alors évidemment il
faudrait déjà pensé enseigner
l'évolution à ceux qui en sont les
acteurs
c'est à dire vous avez vu les
agriculteurs qui par exemple gère
l'évolution des pathogènes ou les
mauvaises herbes
d'une certaine façon les médecins qui
gèrent l'évolution des microbes et des
microbes qu'on soit le moins ces gens là
sont les gestionnaires effectif
ont-ils de l'évolution dans leurs études
pour nous parler des médecins par
exemple il ya quelques universités où on
voit se développer la médecine dite
darwinienne où la médecine évolutive qui
prend en compte l'évolution mais c'est
le fait d'une poignée de profs
deux décisions individuelles ça n'est en
rien un passage obligatoire alors que
évolué c'est un peu obligatoire quand on
est vivant et non seulement des
spécialistes comme ça les agriculteurs
les pêcheurs où les médecins ont besoin
d'évolution mais tous ses concitoyens en
ont besoin pour comprendre ce qui se
passe vous savez c'est même plus
d'ailleurs que de la biologie c'est une
question philosophique
quand va-t-on expliquer dès la petite
école que le présent est le produit de
ce qui l'a précédé et le début de ce qui
va lui succéder
finalement l'aspect évolutif et
biologique n'est qu'une facette de cette
inscription dans le temps et dans le
changement perpétuel et donc il faut
commencer très tôt à enseigner ça je
suis pas sûr que les sciences de
l'évolution est un temps d'antenne
suffisant ni d'ailleurs que nous soyons
prêts demain à réellement prendre en
main mais il le faut il ya une forme
d'urgence c'est notre efficacité qui est
en cause c'est notre efficacité et notre
capacité à transmettre un monde qu'ils
soient imputables aux générations
suivantes alors oui oui l'évolution
d'une belle au bois dormant et la
rupture
ce sera le moment où quelqu'un enfin ira
lui donner ce baiser qui fera d'elle
l'aune de notre action je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]